from the author of rikki-tikki-tavi and
the white man's burden uh-oh comes the
animated classic that will get bare
necessities stuck in your head and have
you struggling to remember anything else
The Jungle Book before you catch the
latest live-action remake of an old
Disney classic go inside the jungle book
book movie for a barely feature-length
collection of random scenes tied
together by a plight as thin as an
orphans loincloth as this young boy has
passed from one jokey singing animal to
another until a tiger finally shows up
and probably burns to death the end
journey deep into the Indian jungle
reimagined is a swing of 1960s hipster
bar to hang with a bunch of jazzy bebop
and animals a couple of squares and
donors and a half-naked little boy that
everyone is extremely touchy with nod if
we don't do that here have a banana I
know what you're trying to do give us a
smile stranger danger stranger danger
stro aimlessly along with mowgli this
illiterate unvaccinated child it really
should have been eaten by now he's so
stubborn and whitey you almost
understand why he got abandoned by his
parents abandoned by his wolf parents
man-cub can no longer stay with a pack o
bendin by his Panther dad I'm nah you're
on your own
abandoned by a troupe of elephants I've
no man come in my jungle and abandoned
by his builder dad again I give up until
he finally gets the chance to abandon
them back and do God knows what to that
little girl enjoy Disney signature
handcrafted animation then enjoyed again
as they recycle the same shots over and
over
could look out for yourself can you you
have the word of the year but don't just
stand there young and helpless then
recycle them even more in other Disney
movies
that's like Michael Bay lazy so forget
the plot because there isn't one
and besides you're only here for that
great song and a bunch of others you
couldn't name with a gun to your head
featuring the is this even a song song
there's no need to sing the long cuz
it's barely is a song it's a lotta told
it's a boring troll but there's no need
to prolong so let's hit this boring song
the time killing jibberish song booming
Diaries I gotta kill some screens as
long as woman as long as it otherwise my
songs arise the touchy uncle song I'm
REE put on trust
like a van with free candy
the weakened pork would were owner song
you wanna lead
I'll firt with you from a distance till
the day that we can walk
and the only song that you actually
remember look Dora oh this refugee with
dr. pol this refugee don't start your
getting lie yes you're a liability you
almost ends up killing me can be alive I
would eat you to Side Story Jammu Glee
the big Balu ski black panther tiger
scar the exact same voices
winnie-the-pooh creepy right and Louie
arms long the jungle boar
so wait isn't this movie supposed to set
up tailspin
why didn't blue just fly Mowgli back
home in the sea doc this movie may have
been boring but we can all agree that
tailspin was freakin awesome right be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers hey screen junkies did you know
we get extra honest about our own honest
trailers with honest commentaries on
screen junkies calm click the boxes
below to watch the honest trailer for
Star Wars Force awakens and to see our
honest commentary on it deleted jokes
bonus clips and special guests huh metal
gear you are that ninja I made out of
laughing taffy tell me do you bleed ah I
mean do you want to join the Justice
League Martha why did you say that name
my butt cheeks are made of metal I will
kill you till you die to death